[Música]
y con nuestro segundo invitado el día
tengo el honor de estar con carlos vive
es una persona que yo admiro muchísimo
sigo su música como todo buen latino que
somos carlos gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
la verdad es un placer tenerte aquí con
nosotros quiero estar con ustedes en
directo américa y bueno gracias por la
invitación
carlos hablemos de cambiar a los relatos
de un mundo perdido cómo fue esta
creación de pasar de hacer música y
traspasarlo al papel hacer este este
libro maravilloso y contando la historia
de la cumbia
y gracias a este
la música en decidir trabajar como con
la música de mi localidad a los
vallenatos a entender que eran hijos de
la cumbia y
trabajar después como regodearnos
trabajando con toda la diversidad de
ritmos eso me mostró un territorio
en el territorio que coincide con el
nacimiento de juglares de lugares donde
nacieron canciones donde están los todo
con cuerdas el territorio con viana con
cuerda con un lugar
anfibio porque con viana es el mundo
anfibio
desde que es colombia colombia es un
gran país anfibio entonces es así
especialmente por eso la música me
enseñó que había que y que había un
territorio específico que contaba el
origen que contaba toda la historia de
lo que pasaba y que además era un
territorio que olvidamos
entonces me conecto con mi tierra del
olvido en ese comienzo de mi búsqueda de
mis cosas y quién necesita
entonces es maravilloso que
devolverle a la música y a su gente y al
el país que nos ha dado todo esto y a
ese territorio
devolverle devolverle todo el amor que
nos ha dado el cariño del éxito la
música la diversidad y por eso no se
cambia na
e ir a buscar una palabra
porque siempre nos hemos visto en
pedacitos
siempre hemos tenemos nuestros pequeños
nacionalismos que no nos apartan siempre
y nos hacen ver como segmentados con
viana fue la palabra donde nos podemos
ver desde arriba todos
no solamente el río grande de la
magdalena sino que también es el atrato
y el san jorge y yo creo sino y también
es el río césar el que cuentan la
historia de los vallenatos
hizo una ciénaga grande pero no
solamente la ciénaga grande o delta del
río magdalena sino la ciénaga de
zapatosa y las tinajas de lorica y los
montes de maría todo ese territorio
que lo hemos llamado de diferentes
nombres yo encontré una sola palabra
para llamarlo porque es el origen de
nuestra música y se llama cumbia carlos
que bonito escucharte porque estás
completamente enamorada de tu país qué
rico se decía ese sentimiento ese
sentimiento que imagino que esos años de
recorrer si
gracias pero decir que todo el
agradecimiento
de valorar que no empiezan a ver que no
hemos sido justos
con todo lo que nos ha dado nuestro país
carlos el cual es importancia de la
cumbia en colombia en esta tierra si ese
es el primer sonido que muestra
todo lo que todo lo que somos y por eso
el afán de cumbia na era contar algo que
no se ha dicho que lo dijeron los
grandes maestros
están en sus libros nuestros grandes
profesores los psicólogos folcloristas
nos hablaron de ese origen americano
es decir de y contrasta con lo que
buscamos y encontramos en internet
el
95% de las historias que cuentan la
cumbia que encontramos en internet
comienzan diciendo con la llegada de los
hombres esclavizados a los puertos de
cartagena llega a entre sí llega la
cumbia y realmente es muy importante el
papel de nuestras hermanas de nuestra
hermana áfrica en toda su dimensión que
nos habitaron después pero había que
contar la historia desde los pueblos
anfibios desde el origen desde antes de
la llegada de españa desde antes de la
llegada de europa ya habían vestigios de
lo que era y de lo que hoy conocemos
como la cumbia un ritmo
nativo como las ranas así como ciertos
animales que son endémicos nuestras la
cumbia es endémica de colombia y no se
encuentra en ningún folklore ni de
origen africano ni de origen indígena en
ninguna parte del mundo un ritmo tan
particular como la cumbia eso demuestra
que es tiene un origen americano
originario nuestro y de esos primeros
tambores no llegaron del áfrica después
llegaron del áfrica más tambores que
enriquecieron toda la locura que es
nuestra música si no estoy subestimando
la importancia de áfrica en nuestra
cumbia pero es importante tener claro y
era la familia en cumbia na cambiar un
poquito lo que se dice y en el olvido en
que hemos llevado ese origen americano
de la cuna entremos un poquito en aguas
pantanosas la cumbia se originó en
colombia qué pasa con méxico qué pasa
qué pasa con perú por ejemplo con
argentina lo digo también por nuestro
dice internacional que en estar diciendo
carlos por aquí también tenemos un claro
claro
y es justo que la gente se sienta dueña
de la cumbia es que es lo normal pero
qué fue lo que pasó porque méxico y por
qué argentina y por qué pero tienen
cumbia
porque cuando llegó la industria de la
grabación es decir cuando alguien dijo
ah yo puedo cantar algo y grabarlo y
luego venderlo en una cinta a
maravilloso ahí ya no existe el folclor
ahí nació el rock and roll de aquí para
atrás es tradición oral hablamos del
folklore de aquí para adelante es rock
and roll entonces que es que cuando
llega la industria que se encuentra se
encuentra
en dos focos importantes uno méxico el
otro argentina es decir lugares donde se
hacen los estudios y donde se van a
grabar los primeros discos de nuestra
música
que hay que tenemos en colombia tiene
una tradición oral se llama cumbia se
llaman vallenatos entonces qué pasa las
orquestas colombianas emigran unas hacia
el sur otras hacia el norte e industria-
medellín la industria de bogotá la
industria de empezar a grabar la
tradición oral colombiana entonces nace
sonora dinamita margarita la diosa de la
cumbia' aniceto molina todos esos grupos
emigran hacia asia hacia méxico si eso
no hubiese pasado
si eso no hubiese pasado selena hubiera
cantado rancheras boleros o tal vez
corridos sí entonces ya entiende por qué
méxico tiene que comprar si no hubiesen
emigrado los artistas colombianos hacia
médico y si no hubiese una una industria
tan importante en mexico y tan
interesada de tomar la tradición oral
colombiana e ir a hacerla en discos eso
no hubiera pasado médico no podría
hablar de música de cumbia americana lo
mismo pasó en argentina si no hubiese
emigrado en los wawancó es el cuarteto
imperial bovea y sus vallenatos y
etcétera etcétera etcétera no podríamos
hablar de cumbias villeras en argentina
hasta los cantos en el estadio serían
diferentes
si estos músicos colombianos no se
hubieran ido buscando una mejor fortuna
a las grandes capitales de la industria
de la música ya meses buenos aires y la
necesidad de méxico por eso por eso
entonces hay cumbia de centroamérica
hasta méxico suramérica hasta la
argentina la diferencia carlos de la
cumbia del vallenato cuál es la
principal la llegada del sonido la edad
la edad si la cumbia es el blues ok el
origen si después por colores más
jóvenes nacen como el vallenato pero
cuál es la esencia la sangre que lleva
el vallenato se llama cumbia
y para entender que el vallenato es hijo
de la cumbia hay que entender que el río
cesar que es el río que cuenta la
historia vallenata es afluente del río
grande de la magdalena que es el
territorio de la cumbia entonces alejo
durán
viene de familias que hubiera nacido en
el paso césar que tiene su relación con
el río cesar pero es el primer rey
vallenato
explícame es verdad porque uno tiene que
ver con los otros porque uno nace del
otro lo que pasa es que claro el
vallenato donde se cría en los cantos de
vaquería ya no nace en el río se nace en
las haciendas nace donde el hombre
trabaja con la agricultura con la
ganadería y entonces es el canto del
campesino si en la cumbia en su origen
es un crédito de las ceremonias fúnebres
de los pueblos indígenas del río y ese
es el origen de la comunidad llega a
áfrica entra en lo suyo y matiza con
dependiendo de donde llegó ese africano
y que tambor trajo de que el lugar de
áfrica si entonces es un poquito eso el
vallenato es siempre siempre lo intuí
después ya releyendo a los que ya nos
habían escrito todo esto entendí que esa
intuición iba bien usted que es el
creador de cumbia na este mundo anfibio
que usted lo dice yo lo va a decir una
frase y me tiene que decir de que vamos
a ver quiero saber ustedes de cumplir de
convivencia
después
usted
va a ser una mímica estos son tres vamos
a hacer lo fácil vale entonces empezamos
te quiero te amo te espero
tengo algo parecido en cumbia na
quiéreme
quédate conmigo y contame tus penas
la primera fabricarlos vamos a la
segunda se va poniendo más difícil
imágenes de la mímica
vamos con estado
tan tan tan ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta ta ta ta ta nuestra
seguridad
hay un médico lanzado
ok la tercera que la tercera si está
difícil porque en la misma
bueno vamos con américa
estás pescando con sombreros o sombreros
sombrero varita el mago el mago la bruja
o la chistera
para leer este
hechicera ya nunca quise irme vete una
niña hermosa desde que te vi que lo
dijera te pone cada día más bonita y
peligrosa carlos para cambiar aquí no
para cambiar nada porque hay otra con
viana combinados se viene si si si
vienes condenados yo quise hablar en
cumbia uno del origen dejarles claro que
había un origen muy nuestro pero ya
combinados es como donde nace el
mestizaje porque sabes que llega que nos
llega de españa que tomamos de españa de
nuestra cultura española que está en la
cumbia que tomamos de nuestras culturas
afro que están en la cumbia que toque
tomamos de la cultura del norte de
áfrica en qué momento y llega a nuestra
cultura del norte de áfrica
digo ya que irá a la colmena y familia
que cannes y así como que todo que todo
eso llega eso es un diana 2 es contar la
historia como de todo el baloncito viejo
por ejemplo siguen que es un ballena
tico que hicimos con cámbrico muy rico
camilo está criado cámbielo también como
buen país está criado con esa también
esa escuela vallenata entonces esa nueva
generación de los pelados del pop
colombiano
les va muy bien además porque son
originales porque tienen mucho
transmiten mucho de su cultura en un
sonido muy universal desde la juventud
entonces nos hace los hace diferentes te
siente identificado con ellos en su
momento ansiedad a parte de la
paternidad de todo ese movimiento
ofrece primero carnes y por qué porque
además entendí desde el principio que no
iba a ser folklore que yo iba a ser eso
debemos hacer propios rock pero que
podíamos encontrar que no podíamos que
no era necesario como que copiar ya lo
que se había copiado de lo que se copió
sí sino que podríamos unirnos a todos
estos movimientos de la música
contemporánea poniendo algo de nuestra
identidad y valorando un poquito todo lo
que somos porque además generamos si es
visto que se dice mucho colombia es uno
de los países más alegres ahí es que la
música colombiana es que no es la de
ustedes es muy alegre alegre alegres
quiere vamos a vivir bien de todas
partes porque en nuestros ancestros
españoles andaluces canario no es digno
no puede haber más alegría nos vas a ver
queremos no de nuestras culturas
americanas nativas
este fueron pueblos muy alegres
y fueron pueblos muy alegres su música
como lo contamos en con viana 1era no
habían armonías que son tristes o no hay
tonos menores que su triste no toda la
sala
la cosa musical de ellos era muy hacia
hacia arriba hacia delante muy alegre y
áfrica entiende y después los siglos
libaneses que nosotros llamamos turcos
de verdad esa emigración poderosa
también fue influenciado a la música
nacional bueno la gastronomía la
política todo históricamente pero está
en la música también entonces son
alegría y alegría heredadas
entonces tenemos un gran
es una herencia increíble para hacer
música para que los pelados a las
músicas modernas se peguen a esa vaina
la cumbia nando oscar de verdad se me
acaba el tiempo me encantó haber
comenzado contigo haberme dado cuenta lo
enamorado que estás de tu país de
colombia qué rico conversar con personas
que realmente quieren lo suyo su tierra
y bueno que mejor embajador de colombia
que tú por todo el mundo muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa y en francés y 4 las
cámaras son tuyas un saludo a todos los
televidentes no muchas gracias y una
oportunidad increíble poder hablar de
estas cosas que no se habla nunca
gracias carlos a ti